hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of quadriga coming
to you from the heart of the German
capital Berlin and this week we are
focusing on the political crisis in
Austria and the impact that it's having
on the rest of Europe now the story is
this Austria goes to the polls this
weekend to elect a new president the
likely winner is Norbert Hall for the
head of the far-right Freedom Party who
won the first round of voting in April
since then there's been much talk of the
demise of Austria's post-war political
establishment and big questions about
how developments in Austria fit into the
rise of nationalism and xenophobia that
we're currently seeing across the
European continent so our question this
week here on quadriga is this crisis in
Austria who can stop Europe's drift to
the right and to discuss that question
I'm joined here in the studio by three
seasoned observers an analyst let me
introduce them to you beginning with a
vote kernig a freelance correspondent
and an Austrian himself who's been
covering Austrian politics for decades
now he says it's not only the refugees
there are many other reasons for
Austria's and Europe's drift to the
right also with us today is Alain Posner
a commentator for the Berlin daily de
Velde Alan says nobody cares who governs
a small country like Austria but Germany
has a responsibility for the whole of
Europe we can't afford Viennese
coffeehouse politics he says and my
third guest is Ulrika Garrow of the
European democracy lab who believes that
a wildfire is sweeping across Europe
it's taken in Hungary and Poland and now
Austria with friends looking likely to
be next if iconic I'd like to begin with
you and without any disrespect
whatsoever I'd like to I'd like to
suggest that Austria is not exactly a
big country it has a population of fewer
than 10 million I'd like to ask you to
explain to us how and why it is having
such a huge impact at this point in time
well we have a longer
serious of grant coalition in Austria so
therefore I said this is not only the
refugees and my mass migration that we
have the drift to the right wing but
also that people are not satisfied they
are fed up of this political system with
the two bigger parties which are not
speak anymore
and with the wheeling and dealing and
that they are fed up with many other
things beginning from the globalization
down to this interior politics okay if
you've touched on just about every
subject that we're going to be talking
about in the next 25 minutes or so I
just like to ask you to give us a give
us an idea from the people that you've
been talking to in Austria this last
week or so what how bright is the sense
of crisis in the country ahead of the
this crucial election on Sunday
especially with the world looking on of
course well I think many people hope
that the candidate of the Green Party
officially he's independent but he was
chairman of the Green Party for many
years that he will make the election
although there is a big gap between the
first candidate of this F baby of this
so-called blue party I can imagine that
many people in Austria were so
frustrated that they wanted to protest
with the election and they voted for
over for an orbit over and then they
were shocked about his high percentage
and in the result and now maybe they do
not vote in this big mass and that all
the all the other candidates who failed
are in favor of of mr. van de belem
although mr. van de belem is not the
ideal candidate as well a couple of days
ago there was a talk show in India in
television private television in Austria
and it was embarrassing it was done
without moderator interested to
candidates if it really was embarrassing
it's endemic for there for this
presidential function okay if I'll
connect there Alan Posner playing down
fears in Australian you you've dismissed
events in Australia as the politics of a
Viennese coffeehouse but I'd like to
draw your attention to an article that I
was reading in the New York Times
published just about a week or so ago
under the title Austria and the future
of Europe it said history's shadow of
rabid nationalism and xenophobia kept it
base since the end of World War two is
lengthening across the continent this is
serious
oh yeah of course it's very serious and
New York Times needn't look to Europe to
say that it's lengthening across America
too we have with mr. Trump as a
presidential candidate Republican Party
it's a world it's a Western phenomenon
no longer can the Americans say it's
European phenomenon when I said it's
Viennese Catholic coffeehouse politics I
was being just as disdainful and and
actually wrong-headed about it of course
because it is a German phenomenon with
the RFD - and and the point is that you
talk about dissatisfaction mr. Koenig
and and and with with the system in
Austria I go to Ostia rectory it's a
great country to live it's a high
standard of living
it's a wonderful place to be and where
does all this anger come from
it's a strange I don't know it's not as
if people are you know like in the 30s
out-of-work bread lines you know even
people who are out of work have a great
social system in Austria there's a
there's something more sinister going on
sort of almost like a death wish
I mean snow maybe it is no accident that
Sigmund Freud who discovered the death
which comes from comes from Vienna as if
they want to just destroy everything
that these that that European democracy
Austrian democracy or and it's very
disconcerting because if you could point
to something and say it's this they they
they let that let people down on that
and you could change it
but people seem hell-bent on just
destroying themselves what do you do to
make of all that I'm doing was the death
wish I let's take Freud out of here and
do politics I would argue that it
doesn't fall from heaven first because
there is a sort of 15 year old
traditional with your Qaeda and another
very prominent figure which basically
was the appraisal of modern right-wing
populism which came from Austria 15
years ago and which we by then still
pursued on the legal side on the of the
European Union because we declared
article 7 and we wanted to do something
against there's also quote by the time I
mean that it is something in Austria
which seems to be a little bit okay so
so it doesn't come from nowhere there is
sort of an but it has been undercover
for long yeah and now I think in the
whole development which we see and which
as Alan Posner said rightly which is not
only an Austrian phenomenom there's the
American there's Trump but there's
marine lepen there's I've Davis Auburn
Hungary opponent and so forth so we have
it so now was right in populism and so I
think what has been latent in the
Austrian case now get sort of embarked
by this wave and there is now a European
wave which brings the Austrian potential
sort of to another sort of scaling
effect and I think what then you can
observe in Austria it's not so
distinctly different from what you see
elsewhere which is that there is a
political class in the middle the
moderate left the moderate right which
is creased by to both ends by the left's
and by the right you see this in Germany
grand coalition you see it basically in
France where you have a president
Hollande who is forced by his left but
also by my indepen it's the pattern for
for Finland for Denmark for Austria so
we are building up the margins of the
political spectrums in all countries and
the political class is timid doesn't
cannot react does not want to react and
it's basically building a wall around
itself and we've got Alan Posner saying
this has got nothing to do with the
1920s or the 1930s that people are
living in a prosperous state it's not
like back then with
unemployment and so on and so forth but
people are comparing the situation with
the 1920s in the 1930s very sane and
sensible people are doing that in
private conversations that I have in the
media in general is that what is there
in this this I would not agree with
Ellen on this because there is a
situation that compares for the 1920s
and if I'm not mistaken I was hearing a
story about income discrepancies for
instance in Austria and there was a
report about sketching out very high
income discrepancies in Austria like the
kepi Thomas Piketty did it for whole
Europe and so in Austria like elsewhere
there are many rich people but many
others who are poor and who did not
benefit so if you say that it's all
wealthy and obviously you know I'm
frequently in Vienna it's a very wealthy
town and you can eat well and and
whatever but it's not for everybody and
then if people feel scared about their
own life perspective and they are in err
in anxiety about what they are going to
lose in terms of social help and so
forth
you have the same phenomena of
destabilization of the middle class
which is the phenomena to bring these
people to the extreme right if I can
take I'd like to give you the last word
on this round before we move before we
move on something sinister in Austria
that word caught my attention something
sinister do you agree well I do not
agree with some positions of mr. Posner
I think it's some sort of arrogant to
say that who cares about small countries
and the government of small countries I
have to say that the Chancellor Helmut
Kohl he did care about the smaller
countries and he did consult them or
inform them this is past this is not
done today and the second position that
Germany has the responsibility for the
whole Europe in fact it is like this
Germany has the leadership for for
Europe and many countries so the
neighbor countries are get about it that
Germany takes the leadership but you
cannot say that Germany has their
responsibility what will appear to be
saying is that Germany is bullying the
smaller countries in Europe
yes III agree but not really the smaller
countries because in the case of Austria
Austria was benefitting by sort of this
Germany which had the gains of the Euro
making and the whole thing you can more
talk about the Europeans house who was
really starving about all this you know
austerity policy I think like countries
like Austria or even the Netherlands
more benefited from what what Germany is
sort of was gaining through the single
market but on the political side I agree
with mr. Coony which is that these
countries resent that they have no more
say in the European making and if you go
to the refugee crisis for anybody see
mr. Fineman the form the Chancellor
wouldn't just resigned and he was
basically given order by mrs. Marber
Angela Merkel to arrange this sort of
European Schengen but it was more sort
of Angela calling for the Austrian
Chancellor to give him a task as if
these Chancellor's are not on an equal
footing in the system of the European
governance and I think there is
something building up which in the small
countries now we are seeing that we are
paying a political price for this
because the total of some of the smaller
countries they are powerful in the some
okay well one thing we do know is that
in Austria norbert offers success in the
first round of voting shook the
country's political establishment to the
core and it led as you just pointed out
now old rica to the resignation of the
chancellor vana fireman the resignation
of Austrian Chancellor Verner phiman
earlier this month sent a clear signal
and in Germany the Social Democrats have
seen a big drop over the past several
years and their share of the vote and
the number of party members
Chancellor Merkel's Christian Democrats
aren't doing much better
neither are many of Europe's other big
political parties right-wing parties are
stealing their votes a lot of people are
really nervous right now and they don't
trust the established parties and those
parties are nervous to ski them be we're
talking about their existence here
Oh speak and end up in a tailspin and
then crash our europe's big political
parties dying out
it's an interesting question and we're
talking about the broad base the big
tent political parties that have been
the cornerstone of European politics for
decades now since the Second World War
effectively are they on the way out now
it would appear so and it's very
alarming this is partly to do with I
mean the basic reason for this is the
electoral system in the whole of
continental Europe if you had electoral
system like in Britain
first-past-the-post system then you
would still have as in Britain two main
parties center left center right vying
and there's and and a basically stable
political setup where they don't have
that where they have proportional
representation in Great Britain for
European elections you get comes in on
top I mean a ragbag of what basically
fools and and and this is what's
happening in Europe it's it's
proportional representation which is the
basis of this anyone who has a grudge
for any reason whatsoever and mostly
it's baseless okay it's true there's a
lot of incoming inequality okay it's
true there was a the elites discredit
themselves in the financial crisis of
crash of 2008 okay it's true that they
make mistakes but the fact is that what
is going on here is that people are
voting irresponsibly they're simply
saying I don't agree with the system I'm
the vote for so-and-so they're not
voting for a government they're voting
protest is it a breakdown of political
education I would strongly disagree I
mean people vote for what they wrote for
and that's the right time that the voter
system comparison doesn't hold because
in France you do have a majority system
and still there's money in the pen you
do not see her in Deputies because
there's a majority system sure she
doesn't hold deputy places and they are
study Nationale but she holds 40 percent
30 to 40 percent in some of the regions
of France so the voting system is just
part of the explanation for France it's
no explanation and the second thing is
it's the right for people to be in anger
against the government and it may not
say that the people are working wrongly
or doing making wrong choices it may say
that the political class is not
functioning and does do wrong politics
and we did wrong politics and a lot of
room politics you know the euro crisis
there was everything legal but not moral
there were socialization of
Napster so basically there is a system
which needs to take the blame that
people are giving and what we are seeing
is just this protest of sort of the
people let's call it the people but in
the way the people is the sovereign they
are protesting against the political
class be that bepa Grillo it's always
this you know establishment but the
establishment left the people behind so
instead of pointing to the people that
the people are doing wrong choices
perhaps the establishment could
understand that their beggar do good
governance for the people the thing is
the thing is the more you want people
not to vote these right-wing parties
those people who want really to protest
they know what the world because you
want to hurt yes this is okay the whole
point about democracy is and it's not
taught correctly in school they say
democracy means leadership by the rule
by the people that's not true
DeMar DeMar cracy means check on the
checks on the rules of the people on the
emotions of the populace this is why you
have the voting system in Great Britain
and United States which is designed to
keep protest voters to a minimum
completely agreed completely agreed that
the majority of the street is no
democracy and the majority of rapid can
fail that's agreed but the thing is that
European populism including the Austrian
one comes always on two legs because you
need two legs to walk one is this euro
anti euro
aside the other is the racism xenophobia
and because racism and xenophobia can be
so easily criticized by the political
establishment look how these people are
you know they are say no for we do not
need to talk to them so they can be you
know shifted away but this basically an
Abe and enables the political class to
not look at the real concret eke of
these people against a misfunctioning
and structural factor the structural
flaws of say the euro governance look
back look aft but for Austria think
that's pretty true there are there is a
fundamental substantial critique to make
which also comes from science that the
euro governance system is flawed for
many people and it does not work there's
no social component as non democratic
component if marine lepen
says this she's
populace but in essence she's right and
she says what most of the German social
sciences say so the problem is only
because marine lepen in addition says
that she's xenophobe or antes limiter so
you can so easily push her away and that
enables you to not take serious a
serious point of critiques and so I
think we should look at what the
populists are saying us they are saying
us we are mistreating people on many
levels of the social and democracy field
so we should rather listen them to push
them away I just wonder Alan whether you
are taking the voters seriously because
you know there are many people clearly
what we are learning it's a learning
process with the emergence of the
far-right in Europe we're learning that
there are a lot of people who are very
threatened disgruntled by by the ever
accelerating speed of globalization this
is what they tell us they feel as though
their traditional lifestyles of
threatens do you respect that do you
have sympathy for that or do you dismiss
that well I mean putting me on the spot
here aren't you no I don't have any
respect for that why should I respect
someone who doesn't want his society to
be modern why should I respect someone
who sort of says I want to live in a in
a racially pure society and I don't want
any immigrants in here why should I
respect someone who doesn't want to
share their wealth with other people I
have no respect for that no and the
problem is not that that the party's
ruling push this aside they didn't get
up until the people you know this is not
how we talk about strangers this is not
how we talk about globalization this is
not how we talk about Europe they
weren't angry enough they said oh well
we have to take your your we have to
take you seriously and then they didn't
and you're picking up precisely what I
was trying to explain we are picking up
these people on the racist and sexist
tendencies but we are not picking up
their legitimate claim that the global
economy is basically making them stuff
it is not let anyone starve in Syria or
Germany look if it was if it's Greece
fine I mean I'm in say I I have every
sympathy with with downtrodden Greeks
but there are no downtrodden austrians
to be quite frank there swimming on the
top let's just say we'll come back to
you immediately after well have a look
at another short report and this one is
in and
banks of what we're discussing here is
the fears that people have about what's
the word identity perhaps we'll come
back to it in just a second perhaps loss
of identity let's watch the pictures
first homeland across Europe right-wing
political parties are playing up
nationalist themes including what they
see as too much immigration now the
split is not between the left and the
right but between the globalists and the
Patriots the globalists who favor the
dissolution of France and a global magma
and the Patriots who believe that the
National Arena is the most protective
for the French and that means for all of
you the National Front has become the
voice of a lot of frustrated voters
there are many of these parties in
Europe Germany too we're Patriots we
love our homeland and we want to protect
it
but can this new nationalism protect
people from truly global problems
that is the question a volcanic
globalists versus Patriots I think it
need not be a contradiction you can't be
a patriot but also fond of globalization
there is a special aspect on the
European lever especially for the
Austrians most people forget it in the
year 2000 we had the first break of the
current coalition it was a coalition of
the Conservative Party with FPE not with
you Qaeda himself but with FP and it was
some sort of maximum penalty from the EU
side on suspicion without being asked
the Austrians without being asked
so the Austrians weren't consulted yes
and this is still a scar this is still I
think then the highest rate of agreement
in entering the EU but after these
so-called EU sanctions it it's a problem
still a scar a scar on the far-right
resentment yeah you know it's there what
is the best way to stop it what is the
best way to address it look the
Austrians elected a self-hating
homosexual and Israel hater and and a
hater of everything truly Western and
and now they say there's a scar because
the European Union decided that they
couldn't allow that that they had
something had to be done about that that
this wasn't the way we do business in
Europe well all I can say is tough luck
for them that we don't elect people like
yog Haider
to be to be part of government and we
shouldn't allow this it's in fact how do
we stop the far-right how do we stop a
far wrong you need to get the analysis
clear the analysis is that talking this
about marine lepen set is basically
globalism comes together with an agenda
of opening so she says she wants closure
but you cannot have closure just on what
side either you have open markets but
then you get the cosmopolitanism
cosmopolitan with it or you want closure
but then you don't have open markets and
this is what we need to understand the
moment the Liberals like Alan Posner
once open markets the open agenda in
terms of who you get other people in
from different nations comes also you
cannot have two liberalism's separated
and that's the cleavage here because the
left ones closed markets but an open
sort of human agenda and the right won't
only open markets but they want to
disclose this identity field and because
these two liberalism always come along
the left and the right are basically
self betraying their own electorates and
that goes to the margins and this is
what we see so this is the analysis how
can it's an analysis of not not of a
solution that's an analysis problem it's
very important to get the analysis right
how do you stop the far right I think we
cannot stop it by order we have to live
with them and we have to make the
reality check if they have some
responsibility in a government and then
you have to i hope so the
demystification and you kind of stop it
by the genie of nationalism is out of
the bottle yeah and can it be put back
in the bottle or is this going to run
and run well it remains to be seen but i
mean the thing is you have to fight it
and that's not what the what the what
the center-right is doing now at the
moment they're saying we have to take
people's concerns seriously and so
they're pretending that these are real
concerns they're not real concerns
they're demagoguery and in that way but
the devil you can only work because the
social and economic erosion is there if
not it could not work like this so the
political class needs to fight that
social democratic emotion okay we're
gonna have to leave it there i hope
we've given you plenty of food for
thought on this week's quadriga if
you've enjoyed the show as much as i
have come back next week we'd love to
hear from you in the meantime as well if
you want to share your views with us
bye-bye just